and but but we can ask the question we
can try and understand exactly what it
is we don't know and try and that'll
help guide us to try and get the answers
and that's what I that's why I frame
those questions and talk about in each
chapter I think the the life question is
so much easier the conscience is one I'm
I'm not optimistic
about that because I think it's so it's
such a hard it is such a hard problem
but not in the sense of traumas
necessarily but but there is a hard
you know it will actually gnome said to
me I I don't know if it was in a podcast
but
um that you know we may just give up
trying to have this you know like
Maxwell had this picture of Maxwell's
equations and it was with any and if you
read all these papers pullings and
wheels and all this stuff because he
needed this mechanistic picture we
dispense with that now we just have the
equations that it could be in the end we
dispense with this notion well we have
to have a picture of how conscious
emergence maybe we'll have at some level
of mathematical description or something
like it